vous avez mis à jour votre iPhone vers
iOS 16 voilà 13 astuces pour l'utiliser
correctement vous avez déjà fait une
première vidéo et je vois que ça vous
plaît donc je vous en fait une autre
comme ça vous pouvez tout voir vous
saurez tout vous saurez surtout comment
bien utiliser votre iPhone avec iOS
plein d'astuces extrêmement pratique
vous êtes prêts on regarde ça on y va
jusqu'au bout c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec mon petit
placement si vous souhaitez placer et
faire fructifier votre argent mais vous
savez pas comment vous y prendre
laissez-moi vous parler de mon petit
placement c'est une application
française qui est hyper ludique avec des
conseillers dédiés qui sont là pour vous
accompagner dans votre stratégie
d'investissement et vous aider à faire
les meilleurs choix mon petit
placement.fr c'est un site qui vous
permet de placer facilement votre argent
et de façon complètement intelligente
c'est extrêmement facile choisissez vous
allez voir vous avez quelques petits
réglages à faire tout est sur mesure et
bien évidemment sécurisé vous choisissez
le montant investir alors ça va dépendre
de chacun ça commence à 300 euros et
ensuite vous monter crescendo en
fonction de vos possibilités de vos
moyens ici l'idée c'est pas de se mettre
sur la paille non bien au contraire une
fois que vous avez choisi le montant
investir vous choisissez la durée
pendant laquelle votre investissement va
se faire plus vous laissez longtemps et
plus fructifiera et mieux c'est pour
vous et ensuite vous choisissez le
portefeuille un portefeuille volontaire
avec le moindre risque possible jusqu'à
un portefeuille un trépide ou là
effectivement vous allez potentiellement
doubler parce que plus vous ouvrez les
vannes et plus le risque va être là mon
petit placement se rémunère uniquement
sur vos gains en prenant un pourcentage
autant dire aussi ils ont tout intérêt à
ce que vous gagnez de l'argent comme ça
ils organiseront eux aussi vous avez
deux groupes importants derrière à
savoir Générali et APICIL mon petit
placement existe depuis 5 ans il y a
plus de 17000 utilisateurs alors si vous
aussi vous souhaitez faire fructifier
votre argent je vous invite à venir
cliquer sur le lien en bas dans la
description pour compléter votre profil
d'investisseur et recevoir votre
stratégie personnalisée et avec le code
Greux grrr vous avez moins 30 % sur les
commissions la performance et merci à
mon petit placement d'avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo première astuce c'est
extrêmement simple dans votre
application photo et bien vous avez des
tonnes de photos comme moi j'en ai je
sais pas combien et vous voulez les
filtrer et vous vous dites par exemple
bah là c'est bien mais j'ai des photos
que j'ai en favori je voudrais y accéder
je ne veux voir que des vidéos je ne
veux voir que des photos voici comment
faire c'est très très simple et bien
vous venez vous cliquez juste en dessous
sur les trois petits points et sur les
trois petits points vous avez pas mal
d'options vous cliquez sur Filtrer vous
allez soit affiché directement tous les
éléments donc toutes les photos toutes
les vidéos tout ce que vous avez ici les
captures d'écran et compagnie ou alors
uniquement vos favoris les photos que
vous avez modifiées édité par vous-même
les photos les vidéos gardez par exemple
je me mets sur favoris et là ensuite je
viens cliquer sur OK et ça m'affichera
uniquement les photos que j'ai en favori
alors vous voyez les favoris j'ai les
favoris un peu bizarre mais bon c'est
pour illustrer le propos ensuite je
reviens cliquer ICI sur mes trois petits
points et je choisis je peux d'abord en
fait non je veux pas mes favoris je veux
uniquement que des vidéos donc là je
clique sur OK et là je me retrouve avec
toutes mes vidéos donc là j'ai toutes
mes vidéos que j'ai dans mon iphone je
viens faire ce choix ça c'est vachement
bien parce que ça vous aide vraiment à
venir sélectionner ce que vous voulez
donc ça c'est cool je sais pas si vous
connaissez cette astuce marquez le moi
en bas dans les commentaires et puis
laissez-moi joli pouce autre astuce je
vous montrer il y a pas longtemps que
grâce à iOS 16 vous pouvez venir
directement sélectionner des personnes
vous prenez vous poser votre doigt vous
pouvez les déplacer les mettre ailleurs
les copier c'est ça ça on peut le faire
avec une photo mais est-ce que vous
saviez vous pouvez faire également avec
une vidéo je vous montre comment faire
vous venez choisir une vidéo vous mettez
pause à l'endroit qui vous arrange bon
là j'ai une drôle de tronche vous mettez
pause vous laissez appuyer sur le
personnage et là vous avez votre perso
qui est là alors là ce que je vous
conseille de faire une fois que c'est
sélectionné vous venez vous pouvez venir
copier directement en haut et ensuite
par exemple le mettre dans une note mais
là vous venez le coller comme ça vous
avez votre tronche qui a été prise dans
une vidéo et ça c'est vachement cool
parce que vous pouvez venir apporter
tout ce que vous voulez directement ici
alors ça me fera pas une vidéo ça vous
fera une photo mais je trouve ça
extrêmement malin vous avez dû le voir
sur iOS 16 ils ont rajouté en bas ici la
petite barre de recherche mais est-ce
que vous saviez que vous pouvez
également l'utiliser pour venir naviguer
entre vos différentes pages vous avez
qu'à poser votre doigt et vous venez
glisser d'un côté de l'autre donc le
truc vous l'aviez déjà avant c'est
extrêmement pratique autre astuce qu'il
y a cette recherche si vous ne voulez
pas avoir cette recherche en bas vous
voulez uniquement garder les trois
petits points comme on l'avait avant sur
IOS 15 et bien c'est facile vous venez
ici dans vos réglages dans vos réglages
vous allez sur écran d'accueil et dans
l'écran d'accueil vous venez décocher
afficher sur l'écran d'accueil comme ça
vous n'avez plus vous retrouver vos
trois petits points comme avant et c'est
extrêmement facile l'autre astuce elle
se situe ici directement dans fichier
dans fichier si vous venez déplacer un
élément par erreur il vous le mettez
dans un dossier dans lequel il est pas
aller et que vous voulez venir l'annuler
très facilement mais regardez vous
cliquez n'importe où vous laissez
appuyer et vous venez annuler des placer
le document s'appelait Black Widow c'est
une invitation vous cliquez dessus et ça
revient là c'est pratique c'est malin
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous la
connaissez dites-le moi dans les
commentaires est-ce que vous saviez que
vous pouviez créer une liste de contacts
très facilement iOS 16 ça se passe ici
dans contact fatalement vous ressortez
dans liste vous allez tout en haut sur
Ajouter une liste vous choisissez sur
quel compte vous voulez la mettre et là
vous donnez un nom à la liste on va
l'appeler par exemple la liste ami et
une fois que je suis là j'ai qu'à
cliquer sur Ajouter des contacts et je
les ajoute directement à ma liste je
vais retrouver ensuite directement ma
liste ici comme ça je peux venir me
faire des listes très facilement alors
une liste d'amis bon voilà on peut le
faire mais une liste pour le travail une
liste par j'en sais rien moi ça peut
être la famille ça peut être les amis de
ma femme ça peut être faites ce que vous
voulez vous pouvez venir créer des
listes de contacts personnalisés je
trouve ça extrêmement malin est-ce que
vous saviez que vous avez la possibilité
de venir régler une horloge un minuteur
très facilement sans passer par
l'application Horloge vous n'avez qu'à
aller dans recherche et vous tapez par
exemple horloge vous cliquez sur
raccourci nouvelle alarme et ça vous
propose de mettre une alarme pour bien
vous réveiller le matin faites ce que
vous voulez vous mettez une alarme et
vous avez également le raccourci alarme
par exemple et là ça vous proposera de
lancer le minuteur vous cliquez vous
avez votre minuteur bref c'est
extrêmement pratique super astuce sur
iMessage est-ce que vous saviez que vous
pouvez venir taguer lorsque vous venez
taper un message voyez par exemple vous
avez des recommandations vous mettez
coucou vous avez le recommandation ici
qui vous permettent de mettre votre
message très facilement ok mais il y a
une autre astuce qui est très très cool
si par exemple vous voulez venir taguer
le nom de quelqu'un par exemple ici bien
je vais taguer Brandon j'ai qu'à tapé
Brandon ça me le retrouve ça me met son
emoji ça me met son nom j'ai qu'à appuyé
et ça va bien serré ici comme ça Brandon
stratégie c'est pratique on va le
contact et je trouve ça extrêmement
malin donc pour ça il faut que vous vous
utilisiez iMessage mettre la personne en
face utilise également iMessage astuce
super cool dans Mail vous pouvez venir
mettre un rappel pour vous rappeler un
email alors des fois il y a des emails
qui sont pas importants on les regarde
on les verra plus tard mais il y en a
certains ils sont importants du masque
il faut que je regarde très rapidement
mais tout de suite je peux pas m'en
occuper ce que vous faites c'est que
vous venez glisser sur le côté et vous
cliquez sur rappel ça vous proposera de
vous le rappeler dans une heure vous le
rappeler ce soir vous le rappeler demain
ou alors carrément mettre un rappel
personnalisé au moment où vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez venir dire bah
tiens je vais le rappeler demain à telle
heure si et ça faites ce que vous voulez
donc je trouve ça extrêmement malin
c'est par exemple vous avez un email qui
arrive le week-end vous voulez le
traiter le lundi matin à 7h vous mettez
lundi matin vous mettez l'heure et vous
aurez votre appel d'email autre astuce
toujours dans Mail vous voulez envoyer
un email mais vous voulez pas l'envoyer
tout de suite vous voulez l'envoyer en
décalé parce que si vous traitez vos
emails à 4h du matin il se peut qu'on
vous prenne pour un taré qui bosse la
nuit vous voulez que ça parte le matin à
8h par exemple et bien voici comment
faire vous venez sur votre bouton
Envoyer et vous laissez appuyer et vous
allez avoir sur Envoyer maintenant bon
ok on connaît ça on voyait ce soir à 21h
ou envoyer plus tard vous cliquez sur
Envoyer plus tard et vous choisissez le
jour et l'heure auquel votre email sera
envoyé je trouve ça extrêmement malin
d'ailleurs dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires avec iOS 16
vous avez plein de nouvelles options
pour venir régler directement ici votre
écran d'accueil pour venir les choisir
les modifier mais des widgets et
compagnies mais il y a un truc qui est
très cool ici en plus et que vous pouvez
venir rajouter directement un écran
d'accueil avec des emojis donc vous avez
différentes formes et le truc qui est
super bien c'est que vous choisissez les
emojis qui vont venir s'afficher alors
si vous êtes en ambiance plutôt ciné
vous pouvez mettre un peu de popcorn
pour mettre un film genre vous allez
voir ça au cinéma vous mettez un petit
clown vous dites bon ben il y avait un
peu de soleil hop le soleil vous vous
dites allez un coup de champagne et des
petits cœurs parce que j'ai aimé il vous
marque le nombre ici des modules que
vous pouvez mettre ensuite vous êtes là
directement donc là vous avez
différentes façons de le faire il vous
le marque là en grille de petite taille
en gris de taille moyenne en gris de
grande taille des anneaux directement
comme ça vous avez également la spirale
comme ça vous choisissez
par exemple comme ça je trouve ça très
joli avec tous ces petits icônes mais le
gris en fond j'aime pas et bien c'est
très facile vous venez cliquer juste ici
à droite arrière plan et vous choisissez
la couleur allez j'en sais rien moi je
suis plutôt vers en ce moment je me le
mets en vert je me le mets en bleu je
fais exactement comme je veux ensuite
l'intensité de ma couleur pour venir le
moduler allez je vais le mettre fort
mais pas trop un peu comme ça hop je
clique et ici j'ai enregistré
directement mon arrière-plan je peux
ensuite me mettre des widgets si et ça
comme je le veux je clique sur Ajouter
je me le définis hop et voilà j'ai mon
écran d'accueil avec mon petit emoji
autre astuce qui est très maligne sur
Safari si par exemple comme moi vous
avez des tonnes d'anglais vous voyez là
j'ai 128 anglais ouvert et vous voulez
les fermer vous voulez pas venir les
fermer tous à la main je comprendrais
parce que c'est vraiment relou et bien
c'est très facile vous venez ici dans
vos réglages vous allez ensuite dans
Safari qui situe juste là et dans Safari
vous descendez jusqu'à effacer
l'historique donner de site vous cliquez
là dessus vous cliquez sur Effacer et ça
vous proposera de venir soit fermé tous
vos onglets soit de les conserver alors
l'idée faut venir les fermer il faut
venir les conserver faites ce que vous
voulez vous avez effacé votre historique
et comme on a envie ici de fermer tous
les onglets on clique sur Fermer tous
les onglets et c'est terminé ils vont
tous être fermé comme ça vous avez pas
besoin de faire un par un c'est beaucoup
plus pratique dernière astuce que je
trouve vachement bien c'est au niveau
des événements et du calendrier dans
votre calendrier par exemple vous êtes
ajouté un événement ici c'est aller au
marché bon plutôt pas mal ce que je vais
faire c'est que je vais faire un appui
long dessus et je vais venir copier mon
événement et si je veux venir créer un
autre événement par exemple je clique
ici sur mon petit plus et ça va me
proposer l'événement que j'avais déjà
créé alors l'idée c'est pas de créer
exactement le même événement mais si
vous avez des événements qui sont très
proches ça peut être une réunion de 16h
une réunion 14h ici et ça et bien vous
avez déjà votre modèle que vous avez
copié donc je trouve ça vachement bien
pour bien créer des événements très
semblables très similaires vous avez
déjà tous les paramètres tous les
réglages vous avez plus ensuite qu'à
faire ajouter aller au marché aux
légumes par exemple vous voyez j'ai ma
petite variante je clique sur Ajouter et
je retrouve aller au marché aller au
marché aux légumes très malin voilà pour
ces quelques astuces sur iOS j'espère
que ça vous aura été utile dites moi si
vous en connaissez d'autres vous voulez
qu'on continue à faire des astuces pour
vous aider à bien utiliser votre iPhone
avec iOS 16 il y a plein de choses à
dire encore plein d'astuces à vous
donner à vos commentaires pour me dire
si vous en voulez plus oui ou non et
n'oubliez pas de vous dire vous abonner
parce qu'on parle toujours tag toujours
plus de Take ici bien évidemment et
ailleurs que ce soit sur Youtube short
sur Tik Tok Instagram Real c'est un peu
partout voilà je vous embrasse à très
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]